now to another big story on capitol hill
serious new charges against members of
the far-right group proud boys including
the group's former leader enrique tario
they're facing charges of sedition in
connection with the january 6th attack
on the capitol catherine herridge is
outside the justice department with more
catherine good morning
good morning dana this is a major move
by the justice department and the same
week the january 6 committee will begin
making its case alleging the attack was
part of a broad and well organized
conspiracy
late yesterday the justice department
announced the leader of the far right
proud boys enrique torrio and four
associates have been charged with
seditious conspiracy for their alleged
role in the attack on the capital
dominick pizzola who is allegedly seen
breaking a capital window with a police
shield is among those named in the
indictment this is only the second time
a group tied to january 6 faces the rare
and very serious charge of conspiring to
block the execution of u.s law or
overthrow the u.s government members of
the oath keepers militia group were
charged earlier this year while tario
was not on the capitol grounds the new
indictment alleges that at the end of
2020 he and his co-defendants conspired
to prevent hinder and delay the
certification of the electoral college
vote and on january 6 directed mobilized
and led members of the crowd into the
capitol complex all defendants have
pleaded not guilty to earlier charges
and remain detained more than 800
individuals have been arrested in nearly
50 states for alleged crimes connected
to the breach
catherine thank you